michael wants to know as an entrepreneur
how do you feel about government
officials picking winners like win
getting approval for casino in Boston
Michael first and foremost I agree with
you 100% this kind of government
interface behind-the-scenes stuff
happens all day long especially
non-american it happens in America all
day long but you start getting into
other parts of the world there's a lot
of shenanigans going on but I'll be
honest with you as an entrepreneur and
I've always felt this way and don't
forget I come from a regulated industry
business where Wine Library had plenty
of headaches I just completely dis I
just completely ignore it I'm
disinterested and not focused on it at
all I spent all of my time and I mean
all of it I spent all of my time are the
things that I can control it's why I
fear the health and well-being of the
people I love and care for because I'm
not in control but when it comes to
business even though there's a lot of
back end deals people not rooting for me
deals that were made for me not to win I
feel that I have the talent and the
skills to still break through